what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we're going to be talking
about the darker side of the MCU the
super natural side with movies like
blade coming and characters like blade
and The Dark Knight and characters like
werewolf by Knight that have already
been introduced we're starting to see a
little bit of a different direction that
Marvel will be heading a direction that
many fans have already been enjoying
werewolf by Knight was a big success and
Multiverse of Madness wasn't for
everybody but a lot of people did like
the horror aspect to it so if you're
excited about this side of the MCU we
have really exciting news for you it
sounds like Ghost Rider and of course
like we've been talking about Mephisto
are making their way to the MCU and
sooner rather than later as well
Mephisto is coming in Phase five and it
sounds like Ghost Rider could be coming
in Phase 5 or possibly early phase six
and for those of you who may be thinking
I'm thinking it too this is probably
setting up the midnight Suns to debut
the MCU Marvel Studios is President
Kevin feige has already confirmed that
the MCU is going to take many different
directions and we are going to see many
different teams we have the cosmic side
of the MCU and our Cosmic team that
consists of the Guardians of the Galaxy
and other characters like Captain Marvel
Miss Marvel and Thor then of course we
have our street level Avengers team that
is about to be formed then we're going
to have the Young Avengers team
eventually formed in the MCU and then
our Supernatural team is most likely
going to be the midnight Suns and so
like I mentioned the next project that
we could get for this Supernatural side
of the MCU could be Ghost Rider we've
actually had several reports from some
insiders stating that Ghost Rider is
coming but the account film Odyssey who
has a good track record with Scoops
stated a couple of months ago this what
I can say for a fact is that Ghost Rider
will be a special presentation and will
be released around Halloween time it
will also feature tie-ins to other
characters we've already met so if this
is true we do in fact know that Ghost
Rider is going to be a special present
presentation just like werewolf by night
was and we know that it's going to be
released on Halloween this year so we
actually kind of have a release date if
Marvel kind of keeps to the same thing
they did with werewolf by Knight that
means they'll probably release Ghost
Rider the special presentation about two
weeks before Halloween so mid-october
and maybe even earlier werewolf By Night
came out October 7th so we could even be
looking at early October but October
2023 this year is when the release date
is going to be now this report from film
Theory also stated that we are going to
see other characters that this movie
will tie into well of course there's
always the possibility that it could tie
into werewolf by night two films two
special presentations with the same
genre now originally I would say that
blade is going to be connected in tie-in
because originally the blade release
date was November of 2023 however now
unfortunately it has been pushed back to
September 6th of 2024 and since the
report from film Odyssey states that
it's going to tie into other care
characters we've already met I'm
thinking that this report is actually
referring to Mephisto now if you haven't
heard about this no I'm not kidding
Sasha barakowen is supposed to be
playing Mephisto in the MCU most people
know him as Borat and here's a couple of
connections here he's supposed to be
making his MCU debut in the Iron Heart
Series so the ironheart series and
mephisto's MCU debut will come before
the Ghost Rider special presentation and
here's the thing how does Ghost Rider
get his powers in the comics now whether
you are talking about Johnny Blaze or
Danny catch the answer is the same both
of them get their powers as a result
from Mephisto I'm thinking we're
probably going to get Johnny Blaze in
the MCU and Johnny Blaze gets cursed by
Mephisto bonding him with the demon
zarathos transforming Johnny into the
spirit of Vengeance so Ghost Writer is a
direct result of Mephisto and the timing
of this seems to have lined up plus not
to mention film Odyssey heard and
tweeted this in replies to the rumors
that Sasha bear Cohen is going to be
playing me Fisto they stated four film
deal as well from what I heard a few
weeks back so Sasha Baron Cohen could
have a four movie deal or we should say
a four projects deal since we know one
is going to be ironheart and it looks
like the second could be Ghost Rider
which just makes sense if we are going
to do somewhat of an origin story of
Ghost Rider in the MCU it would make
sense that the demon Mephisto would be a
part of that now as far as the other two
projects that Mephisto could pop up in
there's actually one super cool story
from the comics that could link three
different people together and those
three people are of course Mephisto but
then Dr Strange and Dr Doom now Mephisto
has connections to both doctor strange
and Dr Doom separately but the story of
when Dr Doom and Doctor Strange combine
to go and take on Mephisto is actually
quite amazing in the comics a long story
made short Dr Doom's mother Cynthia Von
Doom gets taken by Mephisto to the hell
realm and is held prisoner there Dr Doom
tries over and over and over again to go
down into the hell Dimension make his
way to Mephisto and break his mother out
but is unsuccessful each time despite
how powerful of a sorcerer he was so one
time he gets the help of doctor strange
and the two of them go down and they
basically defeat Mephisto by tricking
him a little bit and they are for the
most part successful they end up
breaking her out of the actual realm
that Mephisto was in however she is
still kind of trapped inside of a realm
but this realm is much better and she is
actually able to communicate with her
son Victor Von Doom so she ends up not
being trapped with Mephisto this is an
awesome storyline and we know that Dr
Doom is making his way to the MCU and
probably is going to be making his way
to the MCU relatively soon there's been
a lot of talk about him recently and
several insiders have said that he's
coming before Secret Wars and he is
going to also add to the more darker
side of the MCU along with Doctor
Strange because a lot of people seem to
forget that Dr Doom is one of the most
powerful Sorcerers to ever exist in
Marvel Comics and it seems like that is
the side that we're really going to be
getting from him aside that we haven't
really seen on screen that much so this
era of Magic the supernatural side that
is coming to the MCU is going to be
really really awesome and doom is going
to play a big part of that also today
Insider my time to shine hello stated
that Agatha is going to play a big part
in the future of the MCU now obviously
we are getting Agatha coven of chaos but
this implies that she's going to appear
in much more than just that show and
since this whole Supernatural site is
really coming to fruition pretty soon
I'm assuming she'll have run-ins with
Mephisto as well and possibly Doctor
Doom because in the comics she is the
babysitter for the son of Reed Richards
and Sue storm of the Fantastic Four
their son Franklin Richards and of
course we know Dr Doom is connect to the
Fantastic Four as well so Agatha could
be running into Victor Von Doom and
Mephisto in fact I would fully expect
that to happen in the MCU so as far as
this awesome new side of the MCU that is
coming the characters that we're going
to be getting are pretty dang cool Ghost
Rider should be coming soon of course we
have Blade the Black Knight Doctor
Strange of course we can't forget him
we've gotten word that the Punisher
could be coming back as well we have
werewolf By Night Clea is now in the MCU
so is Elsa Bloodstone and then we'll
have villains like Agatha Doctor Doom
and the man the myth the legend Mephisto
so lots of exciting things ahead before
Secret Wars actually gets here so the
next few years of Marvel are going to be
top tier so let us know your thoughts
about this down below and how excited
you are for the future of Marvel and
this new Supernatural side don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on the latest MCU news you
can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf